so here geek culture as you can tell we
love our gaming chairs especially give
me chance from secret lab so we've got
the aces AC put the AC system so we have
the Assassin's Creed Edition we have our
classic Titan Evo 2022 Zinnia over there
has a secret lab Charizard Edition very
very nice with that nice DOTA plush
Lumber support So secret life has
addressed a solution for the problem
that we're having in the circular
Community where if you live in kind of
more humid climates like here in
Singapore the full leather
on your seats in your chair tends to
peel and tear off that's not really good
if you're making a very expensive
investment so behold secret chair skins
soda purple for the secret Titan Evo
2022 whether it's compatible with your
previous year chairs
we don't know we have to also add a
disclaimer
this is pre-production as well so the
material the colors the Styles quite a
bit different by the time we've launched
this video so do check out the website
for more details let's start with the
unboxing take out the sleeve
there we go oh oh there you go what does
it say
okay
yo you gotta take the whole thing out
man I was under the assumption is
something where you just way over like
those Ikea sofas yeah it's the whole
thing yeah so we gotta kind of do the
back rest and the seat base
that's about it but it should be easy I
hope refresh your chairs as if it smells
good so this is the back seat sleeve and
the seat base leave
first impressions
it's the same soft weave material that
you get out of the box if you bought an
actual
softly circulatory yeah
not really it smells fresh it smells
good smells like Ikea
it does smell like Ikea this is the seat
no it's the embroidered and everything
yeah I mean you're not losing any
quality here
stitching is all good as always so all
we need to do now is to transform this
chair give it a nice Extreme Makeover
with soda purple it's soft meat so
there's basically nine steps for the
back rest sleeve assembly and six steps
for the seat base Leaf assembly and it's
pretty cool because the first step tells
you to actually unzip side and bottom
zippers here on the chair oh
so what's up
oh uh it's not visible
so it's really just yeah it's really a
slip-on it's all you need to do is slide
right
in the backrest
all right
and just
unzip everything on the purple yeah and
zip the and zop zip the sides here and
the bottom over here
basically
like putting one underwear guys it's
that easy wow brand new
it's even got the cutouts for the lumbar
support we got a slide forward now so
that it can get it from underneath
yeah so that's why you have these um
pull tabs
here
oh I know why I know what's going on
yeah it makes it so much easier man they
think of the ergonomics so well so just
pull
let's set the sides
that
okay I guess we'll just talk these boys
in tuck it in we install news
bingo
mango all right cool Bob's your uncle so
obviously there will be one narrow end
one of you one wider end so the wider
end is the front
of the chair you have like a nice great
elastic
material here
so we're gonna just the buckles here
kind of you gotta do the thing a bit
forward
right and then search stuck it in there
so you can pull the buckle
yeah like so repeat the process for the
other side
then we're gonna
adjust the backrest back again
so I'm guessing this part kind of aligns
with that
as we go
here pull more
just yeah you can really
pull back so the final touches after
you've adjusted all
the uh the fabric you see that there's a
loose stitching here because
pre-production unit and I'm sure the
Polish shade up even more and you got
this plastic flap so it's not meant to
lay over
the uh the side here it's supposed to
tuck it in the plastic sheath over here
and then just push it in and then
right on top
all you need to do is just tuck in the
stitching and Bing Bang Boom
then the buckle
roll it through like this so
above the lever
and clip and pull to tighten to tighten
tighten
okay
and then bingo bango man
dude that's what it is man
that's it sweet nice this feels pretty
good that looks good yeah maybe because
I like soft Leaf a lot more than leather
but you've seen how quick it is to
assemble this
fast and easy very convenient
yeah we are ready to rock and roll start
your gaming and you're working you're
gaming and you're working so we're gonna
test this out a little bit more playing
some games doing some work before we get
into our final thoughts and speaking of
which you know what's a great work
companion well an MSI laptop right this
video is brought to you by MSI meet the
summit e16 flip featuring the latest
12th gen Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30
series graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD
Plus touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime
this thing pretty much looks like any
other soft weave chair right now so if
you guys get tired of your leather see
collab chairs you're gonna try to soft
weave without buying the whole
chair you just get the skins and
I don't think it feels it feels like
it's all free and we sit on it it sits
like a soft weave it's not much of a
difference so the thing about the Skins
is that it does come in all three sizes
so the S the regular and the XLS so if
you guys are planning to get skin
focused chair you guys have that option
out there for you in the Titan evos you
know that's an evil series
and that
pricing yeah is it worth the US hundred
and sixty nine dollars or what Singapore
239 basically like one third of the cost
yeah it's like 35 36 of the cost of a
software fabric Chair by the way it's
basically like a third of a new chair
granted do you feel that the material is
premium I mean honestly yeah it does
it's literally just the skin of a soft
weave on your leather and it's nice to
have that option but right
I wonder if it costs more if we replace
the I mean obviously if you don't want
to replace the wheelchair just buy this
thing that's true yeah here's my
thoughts see the thing here is that I
believe you should buy a secret chair
skin if you already own a soft weave
fabric chair you accidentally stain
yourself with fabric it's something you
can't you can't like really clean
probably like hire a professional
service that costs a lot of dollars just
to clean it but think about it if you
buy a mattress you're gonna buy mattress
covers so it's good to still have the
added benefit of having a cover whether
it's leather or softly fabric you know
you just bought
a Limited Edition Assassin's Creed chair
and then now there's a Naruto chair but
you don't want to invest
in buying a new chair so get a secret
life trash can definitely more worth it
uh if it's something that suits your
style like we like this soda purple
because it reminds us of Thanos and you
know you know how we love our Infinity
gauntlets oh yeah you'll go one day
there you go
where's the third one move it definitely
worth it I can't wait to see more Styles
and colorways and designs from secret
lab so secret lab do hollow at us you
know we love our Avengers and Marvel
stuff and Disney stuff and 240k and more
Hammer stuff imagine the Gathering stuff
I'm just saying just putting out there
you know some ideas just put more here
with that being said thanks for tuning
in to this video hope you guys enjoyed
don't forget to like And subscribe and
if you love this video check out our
other videos
right here
[Music]